uh seth rogen uh is it true that you
credit him with influencing you to make
your work more outrageously dirty well
certainly seth felt like
comedy wasn't
edgy enough for his taste right so when
we first started
working together
uh you know in movies after undeclared
where we couldn't be that edgy we were
you know desperately trying to get
someone to pay attention to superbad and
not having a lot of success
one of the stories that always makes uh
seth and i laugh is that
there was this producer that we added to
our team because we thought maybe it's
us maybe if we had a more powerful
producer he could get us the money so we
we have this producer join our team and
then suddenly he gets hired to be the
head of paramount
and we think well now we'll make the
movie he's the head of paramount and the
first thing he did is head to paramount
was to say no to the movie that he was
the producer
um
but
during the the writing of the 40 year
old virgin
you know seth was one of the producers
on it and
he really thought it was funny to make
steve uncomfortable
so in his work
as the guy in the stockroom with steve
he went hard and dirty and uncomfortable
and it made us laugh
so hard to do that to steve and steve i
think as a comedy person also isn't like
a dirty
comedian right you know you don't think
anything like that you know he's a smart
subtle witty brilliant guy and he'll go
there
but it really made steve uncomfortable
and to the point where steve wasn't sure
where the line should be
in the movie and i think seth was a big
you know a big influence on
a lot of you know that kind of
you know talking about a donkey show and
mexico type
type joke runs right you know and that
extended through you know
other things like you know super bad and
pineapple express i mean he really wants
to put the pedal to the metal and some
of the joke style you take a lot of
risks with with newcomers i see
newcomers like pete davidson and amy
schumer who had a ton of didn't have a
ton of acting experience and so when you
take on a role like that like this is
the leader all we're doing king of
staten island
how much work is that extra on you to
get performances out of someone to i
mean that's that seems like it's a
difficult task you're setting yourself
up for someone who hasn't really acted
or maybe they just naturally fall into
place it's not really about the
performances as much as the writing
the writing just takes
a lot of work
and it just takes why is that what do
you what do you mean because
you know when the movies work they're
usually very personal even if they're
big comedies the core idea of it is a
personal idea to amy or two-pete about
relationships or about getting over
trauma and grief
and so you're asking someone to really
go there
these aren't like ghostbusters type
premises yeah they're very personal
and so you have to
develop with them over sometimes an
extended period of time with amy was
was kind of short because she wrote if
you gave her notes
she would hand you a new draft like five
days later
she really worked hard
and and when we get to the set usually
we've done auditions and we've done
table reads and by the time we get there
we know
what we're doing the the hard work is in
the conception of it
you